let's try to subtract 659 from 971
and as soon as you see start trying to
do it you face a problem you go to the
ones place and you say how am i going to
subtract a 9 from a 1 and the answer
lies in regrouping taking value from one
of the other places here and giving it
to the ones place and to understand that
a little bit better let me rewrite these
two numbers let me expand it out so this
nine is in the hundreds place so it
represents nine hundred the seven is in
the tens place so it represents seven
tens and then this one is in the ones
place so it just represents one
and then down here
this six represents six hundred
six hundred this five represents five
tens or fifty and then this nine well it
still just represents nine ones or nine
and we're subtracting this we're
subtracting 600 plus 50 plus 9 or
another way of thinking about it we're
subtracting 600 we're subtracting 50 we
are subtracting 9.
so let's work it out over here so this
is the exact same problem just written a
little bit differently and we still have
the same issue how do we subtract a
larger number from a smaller number and
the solution lies in trying to take
value from one of the other places and
the easiest place to go is like look
we've got 70 here why don't we take 10
from here and we'll be left with 60 and
give that 10 to the ones place so if you
add 10 to 1 what do we have well then
we're going to have we're going to have
11. notice i have not changed the value
of the number 971 is the same thing as
900 plus 60 plus 11. it's still 971.
and now we can actually subtract 11
minus 9
11 minus 9 is 2.
60 minus 50
is
and 900 minus 600 is 300 is 300 so this
this this subtraction should result in
300 plus 10 plus 2 which is 312.
now let's do the exact same thing here
but we're going to do it using without
expanding it out so same issue how do we
subtract a 9 from a 1 well let's take a
10 from the tenths place we're going to
regroup so we're going to get rid of one
of these 10. so we're only going to have
six tens left in the tens place and
we're going to give that 10 to the ones
place so 10 plus 1 is 11. now we are
ready to subtract 11 minus 9 is 2
6 minus five is one
nine minus six is three
we get let me do that same color we get
three hundred and twelve